تقع مقاطعه خرس جنوبيه اوكرانيا في موقع
استراتيجيه تطل منه على بحر ازوف والاسود
كما تقع قرب مصب نهر دنبرو وبالتالي فهي
تمثل خط امداد حيوي يبلغ عدد سكان مقاطعه
خرسون اكثر من مليون شخص تمتد على مساحه
28,000 و500 كم مربع تشكل جسرا بريا
لروسيا من اعراضها مرورا باقليم دومباز
الى شبه جزيره القرم التي تتصل بها وتتحكم
بمعظم المصادر مياه الشرب والزراعه التي
تغذي القرم تمتلك المدينه اكبر ميناء في
اوكرانيا لبناء السفلي في البحر الاسود
وهي مركز الرئيسي للشحن اضافه الى وجود
صناعات مهمه فيها مثل تكرير النفط
والمسجات القطنيه وغيرها عدا عن كونها من
اهم المناطق السياحيه في اوكرانيا التطور
اللافت اليوم في هذه المقاطعه هو ان وزير
الدفاع الروسي امر بسحب القوات الروسيه من
الضفه اليمنى من نهر دنبرو في خيرسون
واقامه خط دفاعا للقوات الروسيه على طول
ضفه اليسرى للنهر في بدايه اكتوبر الماضي
صدقت موسكو على اتفاقيه انضمام خرسان
اضافه الى لوجانس كودونيس وزبوجيا الى
روسيا الاتحاديه وقد عين بوتن حاكم لكل
منطقه تلك المناطق من هنا فانه قد ينعكس
تحول موازين القوه لصالح الاوكرانيين في
خرسون على المشهد في الجنوب الاوكراني